Поява дитини в родині - велика радість.
Однак німці не були б німцями, якби не порахували,
у скільки обходяться діти сімейному бюджету.
Забігаючи наперед, можна сказати, що грошей,
необхідних для того, щоб виростити дитину в Німеччині,
цілком вистачило б на покупку, скажімо,
актуальної моделі німецького автомобіля "Порше".
Протягом 18 років - від народження дитини до її повноліття -
німецька родина, за підрахунками Федерального статистичного відомства,
інвестує у своє дитя приблизно 140 тисяч євро.
Якщо дітей двоє, подружжя має розраховувати
на витрати у 252 тисячі євро. Троє дітей -
фінансовий тягар в розмірі 366 тисяч євро.
Такі цифри, на перший погляд, шокують.
Діти здаються неймовірно дорогим задоволенням,
яке дозволити собі можуть далеко не всі.
Звісно, необхідно враховувати розміри
середньої зарплати в Німеччині.
Це приблизно 1900 євро на місяць нетто.
Таким чином, якщо забути про нерівну оплату праці
жінок та чоловіків, умовне подружжя, в якому
працюють обоє партнерів, за 18 років
може заробити майже 830 тисяч. Теоретично.
Виростити дитину за таких умов уже реальніше.
Водночас, за статистикою, середню зарплату
отримує приблизно лише кожен третій громадянин Німеччини.
Утім, повернімося до, власне, витрат на дитину.
Близько 140 тисяч євро на дитину.
Звідки беруться такі розрахунки?
Йдеться не лише про витрати, які приносять позитивні емоції,
на кшталт купівлі першого ліжечка,
перших повзунків та візка для немовляти.
Одяг, проїзд, дозвілля, харчування, памперси, ліки,
додаткова житлова площа - на місяць виходить
у середньому 600 євро на одну дитину,
підрахували в Німеччині.
Якщо додати ще оплату за дошкільний заклад
чи няню, то щомісячні видатки зростають до 1050 євро.
Варто, щоправда, зазначити, що оплата ясел,
дитсадка чи няні варіюється у Німеччині
залежно від доходу батьків.
Коли дитсадківські часи минають,
витрати лише збільшуються. Одна дитина
молодшого шкільного віку обходиться вже не в 6,
а в 7 тисяч євро на рік. А витрати на підлітка
від 12 до 18 років становлять близько 8,5 тисяч євро щороку.
Школяреві потрібні не лише зошити й підручники,
а й комп'ютер, велосипед, стіл і полиці
в дитячій кімнаті. Діти відвідують курси,
вчаться грати на музичному інструменті
або відвідують спортивний клуб.
Статистика часто ще не враховує подорожі
в відпустку та школярські обміни.
Дитина віком від 18 років обходиться ще дорожче,
особливо якщо їй для навчання потрібно
винаймати квартиру та отримати водійські права.
Власне, на ці гроші батькам
можна було б купити ще один "Порше" :)
Як соціальна держава Німеччина усіляко фінансово
допомагає сім'ям із дітьми і заохочує народжувати.
Чиста грошова допомога, яка не обкладається податками,
становить 202 євро на місяць на першу дитину.
Мати або батько має право на відпустку
з догляду за дитиною, і протягом 14 місяців
після її народження держава сплачує родині
від 300 до 1800 євро на місяць.
Медичне страхування дитині надається безкоштовно:
вона прикріпляється до страховки батька чи матері.
Не вимагається жодних доплат.
Окрім того, частина зарплатні батьків
звільняється від оподаткування.
Однак у підсумку державні допомога й пільги
не компенсують і половини витрат на дітей у ФРН,
свідчить статистика. Дитина залишається розкішшю.
Утім, дві третини німців підтверджують, що
без дитини не уявляють собі щасливого життя,
скільки б це зрештою не коштувало.